hello readers today i want to talk to
you about why we read more than one text
on one topic and to show you why i shall
use a subject that is very near and dear
to my heart animals that can kill you
this is not a joke i legitimately wrote
a book about this a few years ago and to
research this book about the world's
deadliest animals i read a lot of other
books and sources
so i want to use this experience to show
you why it's important to read more than
one source on a subject
okay so why do it why not say all right
i read one text about the pacific blue
ringed octopus why do i need to read two
or three or 20. there are a couple
reasons let's start with the first
expert knowledge if you want to know all
about octopuses you can't just look at a
single piece of writing and say bam got
it know all i need to know i am the
knower of octopus facts now you can't do
it if you want to become an expert you
need to be able to say well this book
says the pacific octopus toxin can stop
your heart but this one says that you
can tell whether or not an octopus is
frightened by its color reason number
two to read multiple sources helping to
determine or know what's true
sometimes people get things wrong it
helps to read more than one text to make
sure you're getting as many perspectives
or ideas as you can
sometimes information from an old book
might be outdated or information from a
new book hasn't yet been proven to be
true
reading different texts can help you
decide what you think about a topic or
even whether or not something is true
we can answer questions like what is the
deadliest animal or how do we even
define deadliest reason number three to
read multiple texts on the same topic
supporting an argument
the more information you can get about a
topic the more support you can give to
your own opinions or arguments
i think that this animal is the most
dangerous because i've read a bunch of
different works about dangerous animals
and i can support it with evidence you
would say if i wanted to say that bears
were more dangerous then i don't really
know what i drew i thought i was trying
to draw a sheep but i think it's a
hedgehog if i were trying to argue that
bears are more dangerous than hedgehogs
i would use multiple sources to provide
evidence for those claims bears are
taller bears are heavier bears have
sharper teeth bears are stronger
hedgehogs or sheep are cuter and
cuddlier
sorry two bears it's important to
recognize that different books have
different arguments in them
every book is a different angle right
sometimes it's obvious like a book with
the title deadly animals and how to hunt
them versus a book called deadly animals
and how to protect their habitats people
have opinions and people make books so
that means that books can have opinions
too
are these animals cool or terrifying
should they be hunted or protected
reading one text on a subject doesn't
give you the full story it's important
to be able to read more than one text
compare them and then decide what you
think from that it helps to have a
purpose in mind too as you read oh and
to answer your unspoken question the
deadliest animals on earth are
definitely human beings but in a close
second place is hippos those guys will
bite you in half so you know watch out
for hippos
you can learn anything
dave it out